[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
I'm Timothy Jordan.
EMILY FORTUNA: And
I'm Emily Fortuna.
Our next guest is a real
pioneer, an engineer,
physician, and NASA
astronaut, Dr. Mae C. Jemison.
What an honor to have you here.
MAE C. JEMISON:
Thank you very much.
It's exciting to be
here today, as well.
It's a beautiful, sunny day.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, it is.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Definitely, very bright.
You've had an extremely
impressive career spanning
so many different fields.
What do you see as
through-lines throughout all
these different fields?
MAE C. JEMISON: So when
I think about the things
that I've done from having
been a chemical engineer
and a medical doctor,
and then an astronaut.
And then as soon
as I left NASA, I
started an international science
camp called The Earth We Share,
was environmental studies
professor, 100 Year Starship.
Throughout them is the
idea that we're connected.
And how do we use our
technological prowess,
our resources, to help
better the world writ large?
And I know that sounds
kind of Pollyannish,
but my revelation,
as I've grown up,
as I've looked around the world,
as I've lived different places,
it's that this planet
has incredible resources.
But they're finite--
the resources include
people and their talents that
exist everywhere in the world.
It includes our plant
life, our animal life,
not just the things you can
dig up out of the ground.
And we have to protect
those, and we also
have to understand
that we share them.
And if I go a
little bit further,
it's like pushing the
envelope, not being satisfied
with this is complacent.
I always have to
challenge myself.
And perhaps, I push
and grab on things
that are really
different or difficult.
But for me, the energy
comes with trying something
that I don't know that I can
absolutely accomplish it--
that it's going to require
something new for me, that it's
going require me to grow.
EMILY FORTUNA: Awesome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: During
your presentation here,
you spoke about your 100
Year Starship initiative.
And to introduce
it, and I love this,
you spoke about how
Mars is too close.
Why is that, and why should
we set our sights further out?
MAE C. JEMISON: So I'm going to
be perfectly honest with you.
When I was growing up, I
assumed that by the time
I became an astronaut--
actually, I didn't even
want to be an astronaut.
I just assumed
I'd go into space,
but that I'd be
going to Mars or one
of the moons around Jupiter,
Saturn, or something.
That's what I thought, because
we had all these things that
were happening.
In fact, we had probes on
Mars when I was a little kid.
So of course, we'll be
doing something more.
The reason I talk
about 100 Year Starship
from the perspective
of it's more audacious
than Mars is because Mars
doesn't push us hard enough.
We've been on Mars
multiple times.
We've got Mars' address, right?
We can figure out the
technological timeline
to do Mars, the technologies
that are needed.
The reason we
haven't gone to Mars
is not so much an
engineering challenge.
It's a public commitment.
But what's going
to really push us
is thinking about
interstellar, which
also captures our imagination.
That doesn't mean
that we don't do Mars.
It means let's do something
that's big and audacious,
and keep that in our eyesight.
So 100 Year Starship
was seed funded by DARPA
to make sure we have
the capabilities
for human interstellar flight.
But the real underlying
current there is innovation.
How do we get the radical
leaps in knowledge,
in technologies,
in human systems
that would allow us to go
to another star system?
Now, that's the real
piece, because each one
of those challenges that we
meet can be applied to life here
on earth, right today.
You can't go to
another star system
with humans using the
kind of energy systems
we have today for
space exploration.
You know, the chemical rockets,
and propulsion, and stuff.
We're going to have to generate
tremendous amounts of energy
through either a fission,
where you break an atom apart,
fusion, like what powers
a sun, our anti-matter.
We do fission now, but
it's not well contained.
We don't know how to
control it, store it.
Imagine if we could just
learn how to store this,
what tremendous value it would
have for life here, on Earth.
When you think about going
to another star system,
you have to be autonomous.
So you have to carry
your food with you.
It's a hard journey.
But if you get to
going fast enough,
so it's reasonable
within human lifetimes,
you're going to have to
carry everything with you.
You're going to
have to learn how
to grow your food,
your medical systems.
And right now, when
we're on earth,
we rely on this wonderful
biodiversity of the soil--
the microbiome in the soil
and all of those things--
to grow food.
We need to understand that.
We need to know how
to keep it healthy.
We need to take that with us.
And so there are
all these pieces--
financial
infrastructures-- we have
to change to be able to do
something that's long term.
And if you stop and
think about that,
those are all things we need
to survive on this planet.
EMILY FORTUNA: Space
exploration seems
inevitable with the requisite,
what you call, Team Earthlings.
But at the same time, it seems
like we could be moving faster.
What do you think
is holding us back?
MAE C. JEMISON: I think
it's public commitment.
It's really that we
haven't included people,
and so folks don't see how
space technology impacts
their day to day lives,
even though it does.
I live in Houston, Texas.
We track hurricanes, and
that's what we know about.
We knew about the
hole in the ozone
from space information and data.
So it's constantly a
pervasive in our lives,
but we haven't told
the story very well.
And when I say we,
that's, I guess,
a royal we about space folks.
And you tell the story better
by having people involved.
What was riveting
people when Mars landed?
That they could-- you
know the Mars Lander?
Remember, everybody was
looking and cheering.
It's because they could see it.
They could be a part of it.
And I think that's the piece.
And I think that's a piece with
all science and technology--
when it's accessible, and
when people understand
that it's part of their
lives, and it's not
this mysterious thing.
EMILY FORTUNA: And they're
energized and excited
towards working
towards that goal.
MAE C. JEMISON: Yeah.
And I think one of the
things that space offers us
and also other
technology innovations
offer us is that we get
to do bigger things.
And I think people like
an adrenaline rush.
But wouldn't we like to do good
things with adrenaline rush?
Right now, we manufacture
adrenaline rushes in ways
that are not necessarily so--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Productive?
MAE C. JEMISON:
Productive, there you go.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Sure.
How does this
relate to your theme
of Look Up and the Skyfie
apps that you produced?
MAE C. JEMISON: So Look Up
came from 100 Year Starship,
and we wanted to connect
people with space.
And we also wanted to deal with
the issue of human behavior.
How do we get the
best out of us?
And we thought, let's ask
people to go out and look up.
Like when was the last
time you looked up?
Remember as a kid,
looking up at the clouds--
and it just made you feel good.
And then I remember,
as a child, thinking
that there are other children
on the other side of the planet
who are looking up as well.
And what do they see?
I know they see the same moon.
In some instances, they see
slightly different stars.
But we're all-- it was just
one of those connecting things.
And so we started
to work on, how
do we create a campaign where
one day, around the world,
we'd all look up?
So of course, we had to
make an app for that,
and that's where the
Skyfie app came in.
So sky selfie, and the idea
is to take an image, a video,
a text, or whatever--
when you look up,
what does it make you feel?
Post it, and we would
put it on a globe
that you can twirl around.
And you can see what
everyone else is doing.
And it's time tagged, data
tagged to where you are.
And you get to see what
other people are looking at.
What we came up with is that
we want to do different events.
So we started on
October 18, one day.
I'm proud to say we trended
number five on Google,
which is great.
But in one day, we're able
to garner lots of enthusiasm
and support around the world.
Of course, it took a lot of
work to build up to that.
And now, we're
continuing to work on it,
and we're going to do one also
around the 50th anniversary
of the lunar landing.
So I'd like everybody
to-- can I do this?
The Skyfie app is
completely free.
No in-app purchases.
I know that's like,
what is wrong with her?
No, it's because we want
people to connect and use it.
And it's available on Google.
It's available on iOS systems.
And the idea is to
really just connect us.
And I think, as we
were talking before,
just the act of looking
up from your phone
changes your perspective.
You get bigger.
You look out.
Just the act of looking up
from your desk or your work,
or sometimes, I'm
walking down the street,
I'm looking at the ground.
Looking up, it frees us.
It gives us energy.
EMILY FORTUNA: So I
have one more question.
This is on behalf--
MAE C. JEMISON:
Wait, wait, wait.
You're going to blame Timothy?
EMILY FORTUNA: Timothy asked
me to ask this question.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Between the two of us,
the bigger "Star Trek"
nerd is probably me.
MAE C. JEMISON: OK, shoot.
EMILY FORTUNA: So I know
that Nichelle Nichols
is a huge inspiration to you.
And I personally believe
that representation in media
is super important.
And I want to ask how
you got your guest
appearance on "Star Trek?"
MAE C. JEMISON: So
let me just start off
by saying when I was growing
up, I loved "Star Trek."
I was in Los Angeles before I
was accepted into the astronaut
program.
And I used to get
my hair cut in LA.
And the person who cut my
hair was Stefon Dominguez,
who was a hair dresser
in all these movies
and things like that.
And he knew LeVar Burton.
And Stefon and I were
talking one day, and he said,
Mae, you should
be on "Star Trek?"
And I said, really?
He said, oh, I'll
mention it to LeVar.
So he mentioned it LeVar.
I got a call one night.
I was at home.
And it's like, hey, Mae.
This is LeVar Burton.
Would you be interested
in being on "Star Trek."
That's what Stefon said.
And I was like, yeah, sure.
This is when the
glasses come off.
Yeah, sure.
And they wrote a part for
me as Lieutenant Palmer.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
MAE C. JEMISON: And
that's what happened.
Basically, it was an
episode LeVar was directing,
and it was really, very neat.
And I was able to go around.
And so I've been one of the
"Star Trek" buddies since then,
and was even able
to help them when
they premiered the
"Star Trek Discovery"
last year, in New York.
EMILY FORTUNA: That's wonderful.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
EMILY FORTUNA: So cool.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Before
we go, is there anything
else you'd like to
tell our viewers?
MAE C. JEMISON: Well, all this
discussion we're having now
is really around science, and
technology, and some of those
issues.
And it's really important
that we understand
that we research science
and problems based
on the people who are there--
their ambitions, their dreams,
their goals, their fears.
And so it's really
important that we
have as many people as
possible doing that work.
We design technology and tools
based on the people we are.
It's important that we have
lots of people involved.
And we fail to develop and
use so much of the talent
in this country.
So I spend a lot of my time
around science literacy.
And I think it's
vitally important
that every child
have an opportunity
for an excellent education,
that every child is
science literate.
As adults, that we
don't sort of say, oh,
I don't know about that.
That's not cute.
We need to make sure
that we're fully engaged,
and that's my task to
be inclusive and bring
lots of people along.
EMILY FORTUNA: Here, here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Dr. Jemison, thank
you so much for joining
us on this show, today.
MAE C. JEMISON:
You're very welcome.
Thank you.
I get to shake hands.
I always shake hands.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]